we're getting to the end
you're seeing i think the downside of
uh
the comforts of a capitalist of maybe
capitalist america i don't know that i
don't know enough knowledge
to know that
but we could be coming to the end of
you know every period of history has a
time
mesologic uh
game of thrones
dragons
uh
columbus
nasa
and what are we in now dude
i don't even know really freelance
so
you're seeing you know everything kind
of goes through its time and i think and
this could be what you know
i don't know do you guys think we're at
the end of times as far as like what
american society has been like do you
think or do you think we're just going
through a little transition period and
it's going to come out bigger and
brighter
um
what do you think on that i'm curious i
wonder sometimes is
you know
are we stuck in this
in this swipe society where we're just
we're literally just swiping for things
that we want
whether they're human or a human
food
uh
instacart
insta heart we're looking all of it is
is
we have access to it all
and so does it all lose its meaning when
it's
right there if you wake up with food in
your mouth man it's
then the part of you that wants to eat
it'll die i think
not the part of you that swallows the
food but the party that wants to eat
but more so the part of you that wants
to hunt
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one